ceci est l'histoire d'un voleur tu
voulais voler à toi tu voyais il volait
aux riches pour donner aux pauvres
c'est tout ce que tu as je l'appelle
robin des bois
vous croyez qu'il est au courant
le chiffre il n'y a qu'une chose qui
maintiennent au pouvoir l'argent je veux
voler le trésor du royaume
comment tu veux faire organiser une
réunion avec tous ceux qui sont avec
nous
rabat comment tout cela se voit à peine
un an d'existence sera fermée tous les
autres c'est du suicide
bienvenue à la cour des grands
n'auriez vous pas ce que vous faites
vous êtes un modèle pour le peuple
c'est notre croisade
ils seront moins quoi pour toi et moi
ils sont pas assis
philippe à celui qui me lie barrage de
polar ça va pas bien se terminer